bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo les missions économiques
changent de formule nous nous retrouvons
dorénavant tous les jeudis soirs dans
l'actualité économique de la semaine
nous retrouvons l'université d'été du
medef de sur fond de réforme
ce rassemblement a eu lieu à jouy en
josas la semaine dernière et l'actualité
politique était au coeur de cette
rencontre
les chiffres du chômage dans les
yvelines en juillet on coud 200 chômeurs
supplémentaires
mais la situation pourrait s'inverser
prochainement et puis les logements
étudiants quelles solutions sont
proposées à saint quentin en yvelines
ce sera le dossier de la semaine la
rentrée politique est chargée en
annonces réforme de la fiscalité choc de
simplification réforme des retraites sur
ce dernier point nous invitons nos
invités pardon nous donneront leur point
de vue nous recevons florence mercadé
choqué du medef bonsoir anne en tailleur
de la cgt bonsoir et dominique russie de
france ouvrière vit bouffier parlons
excuse et moi on vous retrouve du coup
dans la deuxième partie d'émission
la semaine dernière tout à l'heure les
chefs d'entreprise ont eux profité de
l'université d'été pour faire entendre
leur point de vue des images de jonathan
willeman la semaine dernière quatre
mille chefs d'entreprises se sont
retrouvés à jouy en josas pour
l'annuelle universités d'été du medef
avec un programme largement dominé par
l'actualité politique réforme des
retraites et de la fiscalité en tête
le gouvernement s'est voulu rassurant
sept ministres se sont rendus sur place
pour écouter et dialoguer
parmi le ministre de l'économie et des
finances est une promesse forte
la baisse du coût du travail il faut
poursuivre le mouvement de baisse du
coût du travail pour être compétitif
nous l'avons engagé avec le cic eux nous
compensons intégralement les cotisations
retraites par des cotisations famille et
nous sommes prêts à travailler sur ce
chantier
autre annonce une économie de 14
milliards d'euros en 2014 sur les
dépenses publiques tentative
d'apaisement réussi le ministre est
applaudi et pour les chefs d'entreprise
croisé lors de ces trois jours le
problème numéro 1 reste la
multiplication des réformes et de fait
une entrée libre
c'est vrai que c'est difficile d'après
d'avoir une vision objective sur
l'avenir et de faire aussi bien des
investissements pour les investisseurs
et des projets pour les entrepreneurs
réforme il y aura mais le gouvernement a
annoncé ce mercredi un projet de loi
pour simplifier les démarches des
entreprises facturation électronique
pour l'état bilan simplifié pour les
petites entreprises de possibles
avancées qui devrait être voté d'ici la
fin de l'année lors de ses universités
d'été on ne parlait pas que de la
rentrée politique nous y avons retrouvé
des entreprises chinoises pour sortir de
la crise est elle mise sur l'innovation
pardon des images de jonathan rioux
manar l'université d'été du medef ce
sont 4000 entrepreneurs militants qui se
retrouvent pour discuter de leur
mouvement
mais ce rendez vous ne serez pas que
politique les salles de conférences ont
fait une petite place à des salons comme
l'espace business innovation le pays
on y trouve des technologies de pointe
comme cette imprimante 3d une entreprise
américaine venu tout spécialement de la
silicon valley mais aussi des
innovations en termes de marketing
ce n'est pas que l'innovation technique
l'innovation patch une innovation de
rupture dans un service comment innover
dans sa relation à ses clients de leur
offre à de nouvelles choses
tout ça fait partie de l'innovation au
sens étymologique
en comme lui de nombreux entrepreneurs
yvelinois ont tenu à être présents dans
le pays
virginie anthony vienne parler de
l'importance du numérique les tpe
aujourd'hui se rendent pas compte du
potentiel de ce que ça peut représenter
le développement que ça peut ça peut
leur apporter
et c'est vrai que notre approche
vraiment de prise en main de la
stratégie marketing de chaque entreprise
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a des entreprises
qui étaient deux personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui 60 et l'objectif c'est
vraiment de leur dire aujourd'hui c'est
possible de faire des choses avec des
vraies performances à mesure et pas
seulement faire une présence pour être
présent sur internet
la proximité avec les universités comme
saclay et les aides financières explique
notamment ce foisonnement d'entreprises
innovantes dans le département et cela
devrait perdurer un centre de cohade qui
est spécialisé dans la création
d'applications pour smartphones va
ouvrir ses portes à versailles les
premiers corker s'installeront début
octobre et nous en faisons la sélection
des projets la cour en septembre
les entrepreneurs ils trouveront du
matériel spécialisé pour tester leurs
créations
le chômage continue d'augmenter dans les
yvelines sont chômeurs de plus en
juillet le directeur délégué de pôle
emploi yvelines sud revient pour nous
sur ces données cette hausse touche pas
les mêmes catégories de personnes à
surcroît on a une baisse significatif du
taux de chômage chez les jeunes sur le
78 dessus dans ton et 78 est ce qu'on
constate par rapport à ça c'est plutôt
un allongement de la durée du chômage et
qui touche plutôt les seniors donc ça
peut s'expliquer le phénomène sur les
jeunes par déjà un fort dynamisme sur
les contrats emplois d'avenir qui
commence probablement déjà donné des
effets après sur les points peut être
positif ils ont des enfants reprennent
ça peut être croisé d'ailleurs avec une
tendance qui est sûr le travail intérim
où on voit que l'intérim a eu aussi une
approche alors
l'augmentation en termes de potentiel et
ça c'est très significatif est très
intéressant parce que on sait quand ça
commence par l'intérim après ça revient
l'analyse donc plutôt positive et en
parlant d' offres d'emploi des
entreprises recrutent sur le territoire
le centre commercial wen qiang des
clayes-sous-bois qui ouvrira ses portes
le 20 novembre propose 800 postes dans
la vente la restauration encore la
sécurité
plus d'infos sur leur site internet
acquis aux une entreprise de vente
directe a également annoncé un plan de
recrutement dans le département 250 250
postes de vendeurs sont à saisir à
coignières le forum a fait peau neuve
les travaux se terminent et deux
enseignes sur quatre ont rouvert leurs
portes
les images de jonathan vilma l'un il y à
peine quelques mois le forum de
coignières ressembler à ça attention
changement de décor parking refait
bâtiment rénové et agrandi
on passe un dernier coup de peinture
mais déjà deux nouvelles enseignantes
ouvert leurs portes
décathlon et baboo après 4 ans attendent
cette rénovation est bien reçue par les
habitants des alentours
d'habitude je n'ai jamais mais là je
vois qui en fait y'a plein de magasins
du coup je pense qu'on va plus à venir
faire des courses ici c'est très bien
parce que le forum commencé à fermer à
côté puis babou il y en a pas dans l'ain
dans le coin un second souffle pour
cette zone commerciale et un coup de
pouce à l'emploi local sur l'effectif
d'environ une quarantaine de personnes
aujourd'hui parce que magasin sera
ouvert sept jours sur sept
nous aurons environ une trentaine de
créations de postes
sur la région de poignet donc c'était
une grosse volonté de notre part à
savoir que nous voulions vraiment des
sportifs pratiquant connus et reconnus
sur la zone au dans les magasins il y
avait déjà foule la semaine dernière en
tout mon forum s'étend désormais sur
9000 m² pour un investissement de 20
millions d'euros d'ici un à deux mois
fly devrait déménager et être rejoint
par l'enseigné darty
à quelques pas de là les commerçants
comptent suivre cette dynamique le
constructeur du forum a déjà des
commandes pour cette zone de 15 mille
mètres carrés où des travaux de
réfection de toute la façade et un petit
peu du parking mais sur toute la façade
qui va être remise aux six à neuf pour
qu'il n'y ait pas trop de différence
entre cet outil qu'est tout neuf
maintenant et puis les bâtiments en face
depuis le départ de castorama en 2009
onze enseignes sur 15 avait dû mettre la
clé sous la porte
il passe maintenant à l'entretien le
texte de loi et des sur la réforme des
retraites a été transmis ce matin au
conseil d'état et aux caisses de
sécurité sociale les syndicats ne sont
pas satisfaits sur ce plateau nous
inviter une vont nous faire part de
leurs sentiments
nous recevons florence mercadé choqué
par nos membres du bureau du medef dans
des bars et vidéo voilà donc département
nous dominer crucifié secrétaire général
force ouvrière dans les yvelines et à
l'intérieur donc aux membres de l'union
départementale de la cgt
alors avant d'entamer le débat je veux
juste rappeler les points majeurs donc
de la réforme premièrement un
allongement de la durée des cotisations
avec 43 annuités pour les personnes nées
à partir du 1er janvier 1973
deuxième point la prise en compte de la
pénibilité avec la mise en place d'un
système à points pour obtenir un départ
à la retraite anticipé une formation par
exemple la prise en compte du travail à
temps partiel le seuil de validation
d'un trimestre passe de 200 à 150 heures
smic
et puis enfin le financement se fera par
une hausse des cotisations sociales plus
0,3 point en 2007 également par une
fiscalisation de la majoration attribués
aux parents de familles nombreuses
mais pas de hausse de la csg alors le
premier point qui fait débat c'est
l'allongement de la durée
et de cotisations florence merkel est
choqué de votre point de vue cet
allongement donc est inévitable mais
pour vous ça ne va pas assez vite dont
le medef avait proposé effectivement
qu'on rentre dans une durée plus longue
de cotisation mais aussi avec un
retardant l'âge de prise de retraite
pour passer à 63 ans et compte tenu
surtout de la situation assez grave dans
laquelle se trouvent nos régimes de
retraite
on a quand même 35 régimes de retraite
différents qui sont tous dans le rouge
depuis des années puisque en gros ça
fait 30 ans qu'on essaye de trouver une
solution à ces régimes de retraite et au
financement des régimes de retraite est
systématiquement ça se concrétise par
des augmentations de cotisations on en
parlera après et par des reports du
départ à la retraite par des
allongements de cotisation et c'est vrai
que si on attend 2020 jusqu'à 2035
puisque c'est ce que propose le
gouvernement pour mettre en place cette
prolongation des durées de cotisation on
ne résout pas le problème tout de suite
qui est un problème grave à nos yeux
c'est un terrien portable pour vous
dominique rossier donc votre avis est
tout autre vous appelez analysera
surtout les jeunes ça pénalisera les
jeunes et puis de toute façon peut pas
rentrer nous dans ce débat de vouloir
toujours prolonger de maintenir des gens
des salariés en activité alors que à
l'entrée de l'entreprise on attend de
chômeurs moi je pars du principe que
plus on libère un taux ceux qui ont déjà
travaillé qui ont déjà donné en fait
plus on donne des chances à ceux qui
cherchent du travail et aussi d'ailleurs
pour valider leurs points retraits tous
leurs trimestres
donc nous ne sommes pas du tout sur la
même logique et de ce côté là je pense
qu'ils pourraient se faire un transfert
par exemple alors c'est peut-être pas
forcément à l'euro l'euro mais un
transfert entre les cotisations chômage
et les cotisations retraite
d'accord justement vous parlez des
jeunes le gouvernement propose de
racheter les années d'études et offrent
mille euros par trimestre pour pour
diminuer
pour moi c'est aussi parce que je jouis
de réagir à ça on est en train de dire
aux jeunes va vous aider à racheter moi
je préférerais qu'on leur donne la
possibilité de travailler ce serait plus
sain et une société on a d'un côté des
gens qui ne partent pas en retraite et
des gens qui attendent avec les
problèmes que ça génère d'ailleurs dans
les cités je crois que le problème de
retraite et en premier un problème
d'emploi et non de retraite
il imagine que c'est votre avis
également tout à fait sur les jeunes on
voit bien
dix sept organisations jeunes appellent
un mouvement que la cgt et d'autres
organisations syndicales ont lancé pour
mardi prochain
on peut mettre peut-être même voir des
images on
à l'université d'été du medef il ya eu
un rassemblement par les mouvement des
jeunes socialistes et les jeunes
communistes qui ont justement essayer de
se faire entendre sur sur les retraites
est très peu d'ailleurs de médiatisation
là dessus voilà on voit un petit peu les
images donc l'addition si vous indiquez
ces jeunes sont les premiers concernés
par cette nouvelle réforme
pour la cgt déjà cette réforme n'est pas
urgente à deux réformes déjà en cours
celle de 2003 et celle de 2010 lancée
par le précédent gouvernement
aucune réforme supplémentaire ajout d'un
rien du tout elle pénalise les jeunes et
les femmes on oublie trop souvent les
femmes qui seront plus les salariés les
plus pénalisés pour différentes raisons
entre autres les temps partiel souvent
imposés et bien sûr la cgt à d'autres
propositions concernant le financement
puisque pour nous
injustement je vous coupe le financement
on va y revenir puisque ce qui préoccupe
surtout les citoyens c'est la durée de
cotisation et le financement on a
justement demandé à des habitants des
environs
ce qu'ils avaient retenu de la réforme
je vous propose d'écouter leurs réponses
ce que j'ai retenu la nouvelle réforme
dans la retraite c'est que on va
travailler plus dépenser plus
et tout chez moi
donc moi qui ai travaillé depuis 1979 je
me demande à quelle heure mais tout va
enfin prendre ma retraite et profiter un
peu de la vie ça avance pas énorme
il n'y a pas de réformes concrètes en
fait effectivement les contribuables
allaient certainement devoir encore
mettre la main plus largement pour la
financer c'est pas une mesure qui me
paraît très adapté ni la hausse des
impôts donc effectivement l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation paraît plus
plus adapté alors oui ce qui inquiète
finalement ça aussi qui va payer
concernant le financement le
gouvernement veut augmenter les
cotisations sociales une hausse de 0,3
pour cent le disait finalement ces deux
os donc pas vos deux syndicats été
négociée avec le gouvernement mais ça ne
vous convient pas non plus sans
compromis qui finalement a été vraiment
négocier un ça a été dans les
propositions
effectivement la pression déjà donné par
nos syndicats les organisations
syndicales en tous cas depuis avant les
vacances a fait que cette hausse est
limité mais bien sûr pour la cgtg en
rappel c'est pas le problème de ce
financement a toujours augmenter les
cotisations toujours augmenter la durée
nous c'est une refonte complète du
financement de notre protection sociale
et donc de nos retraites
en mettant à contribution y compris le
capital les et les les
les revenus financiers qui aujourd'hui
sont complètement exempt de toute charge
chargé de 2 c'est plutôt le capital
les entrées les estacades ont complété
un peu un pour cent de masse salariale
supplémentaire c'est 685 millions de
cotisations vieillesse en plus voilà ça
c'est un chiffre vous dire qu'il joue
quand ça je pense que tous les deux vous
êtes d'accord c'est finalement je pense
qu'il est important aujourd'hui c'est
s'attaquer au chômage
absolument lahlou jauge presque
qui nous retrouvent alors tous de notre
socle commun à tout cela s'est il faut
se battre pour l'emploi
et c'est vrai que là par rapport à ce
problème de financement depuis depuis
cinq ans les entreprises essayent de
traverser cette crise il y en a qui
n'ont pas survécu celles qui arrivent à
survivre pas oublier que 90% des
entreprises en france sont des pme de
moins de 50 salariés que c'est ce que
c'est que le gouvernement vient
compenser pour le moment on a des
déclarations qui ont été effectivement
faite par monsieur moscovici dans des
universités d'été et qui ont été
réitérées auprès de pierre gattaz lundi
matin mais on attend du concret parce
qu'on a une certitude c'est
l'augmentation des cotisations
on a des promesses qui sont ou va
compenser là où l'augmentation des
cotisations
est-ce que ça prendra en compte ou pas
l'augmentation qui va être travers de la
pénibilité
pendant ces rien on est encore un peu
dans le flou donc on attend des
certitudes mais une certitude est clair
c'est que les entreprises ne peuvent pas
supporter plus de charges que ce
qu'elles ont aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est un point commun aussi
que les politiques qui disent tous quel
que soit le bord politique
il ya trop de charges et à trop de taxes
il faut faire une pause le président
nous l'a dit
donc je pense que quand quand monsieur
dit effectivement qu'on a une réforme en
2003 qu'on a eu une réforme en 2010 on y
revient en 2013 et je pense que si on ne
s'attaque pas au fond du problème et si
on ne refait pas complètement nos
régimes de retraite et qu'on leur pense
pas de telle manière à ce qu'ils
puissent est viable et finançable on va
faire cette réforme telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et puis on se retrouve en
2017 avec un nouveau françois hollande
ou un autre président de la république
et ainsi de suite et ça sans fin alors
justement de cette réforme sera débattu
au parlement le 7 octobre
pour finir je suis désolé mais à peu
près par le temps j'aimerais avoir juste
vos solutions à vous quelle serait la
solution
moi je vous dis déjà augmenté la masse
salariale des cotisations est en tirer
d'ici ce serait mécanique c'est déjà une
solution je dirais presque de facilité
je veux bien qu'on me dise que les
entreprises n'ont plus les moyens de
supporter des charges mais quand on
regarde toutes les grosses entreprises
du cac 40 notamment fo profits records
sur profits records les revenus du
capital
par exemple le les dividendes qui sont
versés aux actionnaires
quand on regarde aussi le nombre de
milliardaires par exemple qui sont
générés par tout ce système là on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya de plus en plus de
milliardaires de plus en plus de pauvres
et plus rien au milieu donc à une
aspiration du capital qui est fait
actuellement le système on est que nous
on ne peut pas tolérer le système de
retraite actuel c'est un système
solidaire qu'on veut garder nous pour la
cgt et on le redit et plusieurs fois
c'est pas le travail qui coûte puisque
c'est le travail qui rapporte des
richesses aux entreprises et au pays
c'est le capital parce que comme je
disais tout à l'heure lui ne cotise à
rien du tout et les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires depuis quatre ans 1,5
ont décuplé
or que la masse salariale comme l'a dit
mon collègue stagne augmentent très très
peu augmentons les salaires
et on réglera en partie le problème
d'une protection sociale
je vous remercie en tout cas d'être venu
genève n'a plus le temps je pense que
vous devez traiter c'était plus une
cotisation privé laissons les
entreprises avoir des marges plus
importantes pour qu'elles embauchent et
on me parle du cac 40 et 90 % des paies
des entreprises ce sont des pme moins de
50 salariés il faut l embauche bien sûr
que si quand un entrepôt un emploi un
entrepreneur montrent une boîte délaissé
pour la développer il jugé
on va devoir s'arrêter là merci en tout
cas à vous trois d'être venu sur notre
plateau
on passe maintenant au dossier la
semaine pour les étudiants c'est la
dernière ligne droite pour se loger
avant la reprise des cours qui existent
pour à saint-quentin-en-yvelines réponse
en images un reportage réalisé avec
jonathan vilma finies les vacances
septembre c'est la rentrée des classes
dans le département au compte 19000
étudiants question logement qui est il
prévu pour eux sous quelles conditions
et à quel tarif c'est ce que nous allons
découvrir et pour commencer direction
voisins le bretonneux à la si belle
une des neuf résidences universitaires
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines mar di
maria est venu y poser ses valises
cette étudiante en droit originaire de
nice a choisi de changer d'université
pour sa dernière année d'études dans
quinze jours elle fera son entrée à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines
une fois les démarches administratives
effectuées on passe à la visite des
lieux
la laverie et surtout maria est ravi
pour l être en résidence est bien plus
pratique qu'un appartement déjà ça coûte
moins cher par rapport au prix
c'est une rhétorique est très bien très
bien équipée et
c'est très calme pour étudier c'est
parfait - de démarches administratives
également avant la remise des clés le
gestionnaire finalise son installation
avec l'état des lieux côté tarif il faut
compter en moyenne 380 euros
la résidence est ouverte à tous les
étudiants avec une priorité donnée aux
boursiers ici 131 logements dont
principalement des studios on a quelques
de pièces est elle à 100 % de taux
d'occupation à l'année puisque
énormément de demande due notamment à
l'université de saint quentin et qu'ils
nous envoient beaucoup de dossiers à
saint quentin en yvelines près d'un
millier d'étudiants seulement hawtin ce
mode d'hébergement la communauté
d'agglomération peut réserver certaines
places en résidence
explications avec la responsable des
logements étudiants odile mission
bonjour un bonjour à votre service
propose différents logements pour les
étudiants
oui tout à fait quelle est cette offre
exactement on a à peu près 172 logements
étudiants répartis sur plusieurs
résidences sur le territoire de saint
quentin
alors il ya des critères à respecter oui
tout à fait donc il faut que les
étudiants viennent étudier sur le
territoire de saint quentin
donc si une possibilité quand ils
viennent effectuer un stage d'une durée
de plus de trois mois donc ils ont la
possibilité de faire une demande auprès
de notre service depuis 2012
il ya eu des évolutions bien vous pouvez
répondre à a+ d'étudiants alors nous
cette année on a la chance d'avoir une
ouverture d'une résidence donc qui
s'appelle rené cassin sur l encours qui
va donner à la possibilité à 161
étudiants d'obtenir un logement et aussi
pour la rentrée 2015 on a une résidence
de prévu sur guye en cours 247 logements
et aussi des résidences sur montigny
résidences étudiants et chercheurs d'un
nombre à peu près de 2 600 du chemin
donc ça sera pour 2015 ça sera pour 2015
en tout sur le département compte 19000
étudiants à peu près au classement du
coût est supérieur
quelles solutions alternatives y at il
pour ces étudiants alors nous on propose
aussi un service donc logement étudiant
donc qui met en relation des
propriétaires qui ont la possibilité
soit de louer une chambre chez
l'habitant ou proposer aussi des studios
ou voire de la colocation on a à peu
près 150 propriétaires c'est un service
qui
place déjà depuis 2006 et qui en
constante évolution donc aujourd'hui on
a à peu près une 300 propositions de nos
jours d'autres organismes aussi propose
aussi ce genre de site donc on a le
crous par exemple qui a aussi son propre
site donc ce qui permet aux étudiants de
faire mener démarche maximum pour
essayer d'obtenir vraiment un logement
sur le territoire en fait à remercier
beaucoup je vais au prix en dehors des
résidences et les étudiants peuvent
opter pour le logement chez l'habitant
ou la colocation celle de julia et
jacqueline est assez original nous
allons les rencontrer
l oms près de 65 ans d'écart
jacqueline ou plutôt javotte comme tout
le monde l'appelle fêtera bientôt ses 89
ans ses cinq enfants ont quitté le cocon
familial laissant la maison bien vide
alors depuis maintenant sept ans elle
loge gratuitement des étudiants comme
julien contre de petits services
obligatoirement qu'il faut que quelqu'un
le soir et la nuit c'est une question de
sécurité c'est si jamais j'avais hâte à
n'importe quel souci faut qu'elle sache
puisse nous trouver mes enfants plus con
filantes qui veulent que je sois pas
seul c'est pour moi le même temps ce qui
pour eux un système donnant donnant et
une réelle solidarité
inter-générationnelle sont ceux-là julia
étudiante en psychomotricité n'aurait
pas pu poursuivre ses études
javotte héberge deux autres étudiants
amjad et idées à eux quatre ils ont
recréé une vraie vie de famille
ça m'apporte une grande chaleur avec des
petits seins comme celle là se sont
comme les petites mes petits enfants
j'espère qu'ils me considèrent comme une
langue pas de doute pour julia javotte
est devenue sa grand mère d'adoption
mois ayant perdu mais mes grands parents
très jeunes aussi j'avais envie de
retrouver ce contact là quelque chose de
les histoires qu'on peut raconter tout
ça une espèce de devoir de mémoire aussi
et
en tout cas et madame chabot c'est sûr
que j'ai trouvé mon compte et ici elle
regarde ensemble la télévision et
jacqueline lui fait découvrir la
filmographie des années 50 pour proposer
ses chambres à louer elle passe par
ensemble2générations une association qui
propose des colocation
intergénérationnelle
trois formules sont proposées logement
gratuit économique ou solidaires dans
les yvelines
on compte 70 colocation de ce type
isabelle etienne vous êtes la
responsable départementale d'ensemble de
génération comment se fait la sélection
la sélection alors les étudiants au
télécharge sur notre site www.ax amble
de génération un dossier de candidature
il envoie au bureau on reçoit ensuite
individuellement chaque étudiant et on
passe un vraiment un temps ensemble de
lors du rendez vous on questionne sur
les motivations sur leurs besoins leurs
attentes
et puis charge à nous après de mettre en
relation avec le senior qui a proposé
une chambre qu'on a visités au préalable
et de trouver cette alchimie de la
formule du lieu d'études
et quand on arrive aux passions
partagées entre le seigneur et
d'étudiants voilà c'est merveilleux
ils marcheront je vous en prie on passe
maintenant à l'agenda noter que vous
avez encore jusqu'au 7 septembre pour
contribuer à la collecte de fournitures
scolaires pour l'association dans les
yeux des gazelles stylo et cailloux
cahiers seront distribués au maroc
tous les renseignements sur leurs sites
dans les yeux des gazelles over blog.com
c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous leur en donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
bonne soirée